hallo deutsch schule punkt ch
hören und nachsprechen
[Musik]
lektion 25 hört zu und spricht nach
er geht
den supermarkt er geht in den supermarkt
er geht in den deutschkurs er geht in
den deutschkurs er geht
den kleiderladen er geht
kleiderladen er geht in die apotheke er
geht in die apotheke er geht in die
kirche
[Musik]
er geht in die kirche
er geht in die schule
er geht ins restaurant
er geht ins kino
er geht ins fitness center
er geht dem
fitnesscenter
warum kannst du nicht mitkommen warum
kannst du nicht mitkommen weil ich
arbeiten muss weil ich arbeiten muss
weil ich schon etwas vorhabe weil ich
schon etwas vorhabe weil ich krank bin
weil ich krank bin
ich lege das portemonnaie auf den tisch
ich lege mich ins bett
ich lege den teppich auf den boden
ich lege
den teppich auf den boden ich stelle die
gläser in sub waschbecken
ich stelle die gläser in sub waschbecken
ich stelle das velo in die garage
ich stelle das velo in die garage ich
stelle die schuhe vor die tür
ich stelle die schuhe vor die tür
ich hänge das kleid an den
kleiderständern
kleiderständer
ich hänge das bild an die wand
ich hänge
die lampe an die decke ich hänge die
lampe an die decke das hemmt das hemd
das hemd ist schön das hemd ist schön
wie viel kostet dieses hemd wie viel
kostet dieses hemd welches hemd gefällt
dir besser welches hemd gefällt dir
besser
mir gefällt das blaue hemd am besten
mir gefällt das blaue hemd am besten die
jacke die jacke die jagd
etwa die jacke hält warm wie viel kostet
diese jacke wie viel kostet diese jacke
welche jacke gefällt dir besser welche
jacke gefällt mir besser
mir gefällt die blaue jacke am besten
der pullover der pullover
der pullover ist blau
wie viel kostet dieser pullover
wie viel kostet dieser pullover welcher
pullover gefällt dir besser welcher
pullover gefällt dir besser
mir gefällt der blaue pullover am besten
mir geht
der blaue pullover am besten die schuhe
die schuhe
die schuhe sind modern
die schuhe sind modern wie viel kosten
diese schuhe wie viel kosten diese
schuhe
welche schuhe gefallen dir besser welche
schuhe gefallen dir besser mir gefahren
die blauen schuhe
am besten wir gefahren die blauen schuhe
am besten
b
und p die bahn die bahn
der park der park briefe beantworten
briefe beantworten postbriefe post
prüfen
das bezahlen
das bezahlen probleme besprechen
probleme besprechen
bist du bereit bist du bereit treffer
und bohnen pfeffer und bohnen de
und tdd und tee tauchen und denken
tauchen und denken tanzen und denen
tanzen und dienen
teetrinken tolle türkei tolle türkei
danach duschen danach duschen dick und
dünn dick und dünn und g&g kalte
getränke kalte getränke im keller im
keller im garten im garten
kommen und gehen kommen und gehen
grammatik korrigieren grammatik
korrigieren großer koffer großer koffer
glauben und kaufen glauben und kaufen
und vfv fahren vier fahren vier
frühstücken und vergessen
frühstücken und vergessen viele froh
fiel der vogel fliegt der vogel fliegt
verboten
[Musik]